when you making fun of people like I'm
Rand who whose followers are basically
well there are atheistic Taliban it's a
political memoir a lot of people thought
it was a lot of fiction in it my take on
it is that memoirs need a fact no
fiction it's the truth as the author
remembers it 9r and I've had a love-hate
relationship with all my life she's she
made a great case for capitalism put on
a moral footing before that it was
mostly a utilitarian argument for the
benefits of capitalism but she was
bizarre I mean Galt's Gulch would not be
a fun place to live in homosexuals would
not like to live there if you had a
beard or mustache you'd be in trouble in
Galt's Gulch so she had a great impact
she was a brilliant woman but she was
also looming at the same time and but
her books keep selling she's reaching
people intellectually out there and
that's and that's good as long as we
don't take her ideas the implementation
of her ideas too seriously
Murray Rothbard idea of his
anarcho-capitalist utopia would be a
nightmare I think because everything
would be adjudicated you would have to
sue anybody that you doing something
that you perceive to be a violation of
your private property rights and your
personal property rights so for example
if you're Donald Trump and your neighbor
is spewing filth into your stream that
runs across your property and you've got
lawyers on your payroll for a
million-dollar retainer will you sue and
you're going to win because you're
Donald Trump you've got very deep
pockets Joe Blow out there doesn't have
a stand leg to stand on Anna Roth
Claudian society I remember having this
discussion with keyworth body and about
a year or two ago and I said what about
people who get a lawsuit against the man
and just can't come up with the
million-dollar judgment he says to me
people can't pay their bills anne-marie
society would be enslaved and I'm
thinking to myself libertarian slavery
that's there's a message that's going to
resonate around the world
the essence of it is adherence to the
Bill of Rights total adherence to the
first and second amendment certainly
keeping the government out of our sex
lives out of our literature allowing
free trade across the border and I
distrust centralized power I also
distrust it on a corporate level two and
I think a lot of the corporate power
we've got as a result of corporate
welfare so to me libertarianism should
strive to strip government out of all
these areas of our lives
if you take the r and model and the roth
body and model and the the freedmen
model friedman's is the only one that
has any chance remotely of being
implemented in this society low taxes
keep government out of most of our
affairs defend the country and and very
little else you came up with ways of
privatizing our retirement system of a
school system and so on I think we
should aim in that direction and then
after that we could have all the
arguments about whether we should go to
full anarchism Annette but we're a long
long way away from that
for a while I had given up on the LP I
mean they were putting up one crazy
candidate after another little good ones
too Harry Brown and a few others but by
and large they were putting up amateurs
who didn't know what they were doing and
had no money this year could be
different and the problem is that you
know none of us are going to agree a
hundred percent with anybody who calls
himself a libertarian either roared
child's used to say you can call
yourself a grapefruit but that doesn't
mean you are one so Bob Juarez taking
positions Ron Paul took positions that I
certainly don't agree with particularly
on immigration and abortion rights but
you know if you get eighty eighty-five
percent of it and you get it thrust in
the right direction that's the best we
can hope for right now and it's probably
this year is a chance for the LP to
finally get on the map in a significant
way